The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Bob has got a
really interesting history
I think is relevant to a lot
of things we're talking about.
You're going to
hear a little bit
about disruptive
innovation, you're
going to hear about someone
that's spent a lot of time
on renewable energy,
trying to get
new technology to
the marketplace,
and about kind of the
trials and tribulations.
So I would encourage you to kind
of really ask lots of questions
and enjoy yourself.
Bob, thanks very much.
BOB DIMATTEO: And you can
ask those questions right
from the beginning,
so I would encourage
you to just raise your hand
anywhere along the way.
So when I was your
age, I sort of
wondered about why there were
little kids in the world that
didn't have clean
water to drink.
And that sort of bothered me.
And it was that kind
of thing really got
me interested in
engineering and got
me interested in clean energy.
And it's hard to imagine
like 30 years have
gone by since that happened.
I mean, you guys aren't
even 30 years old.
That seems like forever.
So I'll tell you about MTPV.
This is a clean
energy technology
that our startup company is
developing to bring to market.
And I'll also tell you something
about my own personal journey
in clean energy.
And happy to take it
wherever you want to go.
So maybe I'll do
a couple of slides
on sort of the technology,
and then you'll
know where I am at the moment,
and then how we got here,
and then we could go from there.
So our technology
is called MTPV.
It stands for Micron gap Thermal
PhotoVoltaics-- blah, blah,
blah.
It draws on nanotechnology,
MEMS, and photonics.
And what really motivates us
is that we think that it has
the potential to change
how we think about energy
because it's a way of
applying these very powerful
techniques-- the whole chip that
we see in our iPhones and we
see changing so many aspects
of our socio-technical life,
if you will--
bringing these kinds
of capabilities
to bear on the energy world.
Which in some ways is, as you've
been learning in this course,
is in some ways, it's changed
a lot, and in some ways,
it hasn't changed very
much in the last 100 years.
We still make heat from things
that we get from the ground.
And then we do things with
that heat, consume it as heat
or turn it into
electricity, et cetera.
Our technology turns
heat into electricity.
And so we start with
photovoltaic cells.
You're all familiar with them.
You see them on
buildings these days.
It wasn't that many years ago
when folks really didn't even
know what photovoltaic
panels were because you
didn't see them around.
It's quite remarkable.
In fact, when I was
just about getting
ready to finish undergraduate
work was just about the time
that President Reagan
took the solar panels
off the White House.
Now they weren't
solar electric panels.
They were just they were
just hot water panels.
But clean energy wasn't--
it wasn't the primary
focus of too many folks
at that point in time.
MIT actually in that time
frame had a solar house, even.
Sort of modern
architecture, lots
of glass solar house that later
came down about 15 years later.
But now lots of things
are moving in that domain.
So we start with a
photovoltaic cell.
You're familiar with
the sun putting photons
on the semiconductor material
and making electricity.
There's another field
called thermophotovoltaics,
or TPV, where we have an
intermediate body which
receives the heat--
the heat can come
from any conventional
sources or solar.
And this body at--
right now, what we're doing is
around 1,000 degrees Celsius,
things start to glow red
around 600 degrees Celsius.
So this is very hot.
It radiates photons.
It glows red.
And those photons-- and
then converts electricity
by photovoltaic cells.
So how many of you have
heard of Planck's law?
OK.
So Planck's law was
sort of the foundation
of quantum mechanics in modern
science in the 20th century.
And Planck's law
tells you how many
photons come off
a heated surface
and what wavelength they are.
And so the photon
flux, the number
of photons coming off that
surface per square centimeter
is given by Planck's law.
And we represent that here--
1x Planck's law.
And there were reasons
that we thought
that if you brought
that real close,
you could do near-field
coupling and you
could exceed Planck's law.
And it was somewhat
controversial in the beginning.
In fact, in a meeting
with Hermann Haus,
who was a real power house
in electrical engineering
and photonics-- unfortunately,
passed away a few years ago--
the first time we came
in his office with this,
he said, forget it.
He said, there's just no
way to violate Planck's law.
And about an hour
later, he realized
that we weren't
really violating it,
that we were operating outside
of the limits of applicability
that Planck himself
had put on the law.
Planck's law says
that the geometry
of all the pieces of the
system have to be large
compared to the wavelength.
And one of the geometric
pieces of the system
is the space between
these two surfaces.
So literally, the gap
between the hot surface
and the photovoltaic surface.
In MTPV, Micron gap
Thermal PhotoVoltaics,
we put them really
close together,
like 100 nanometers apart,
or 1/10 of a micron.
And when you do that, you
get near-field coupling
and the photon flux,
and therefore, the power
out can dramatically go up by
about an order of magnitude.
And so he said, oh OK.
He said, so you actually want
to put the photovoltaic cell
into the near-field or
evanescent field of this heated
surface.
And we said, yes, exactly.
He said, OK.
Well, maybe you can do
better than Planck's law.
And so really this is the field
that we've been pioneering,
using this mechanism which
basically derives from the fact
that inside the hot
body, there are photons
generated in every direction.
It's only the photons
generated inside that come up
to that surface--
normal to the surface or
nearly normal to the surface--
that actually get out.
So in a hot body, most
of the photonic energy
that's being generated all
the time is trapped inside.
But if you bring a surface
up close enough to it,
as those photons
approach the surface,
a photon is-- as Professor
Haus pointed out-- actually
has extent, it has
size of something
on the order of the wavelength.
So we don't usually think
of photons as having a size.
But they have an
approximate size,
something like the wavelength.
The wavelength we're
working with is 2 microns.
The gap here is only 0.1 micron,
so this big 2-micron photon
comes traveling up
towards that surface,
and just goes right across
this vacuum gap between the two
surfaces, act as a
photovoltaic cell,
and then can become power.
So it's all the photons that
are impinging upon the surface
off-normal that get into
the photovoltaic cell
here, in our technology,
MTPV, that do not
get out of that hot body.
They're trapped inside
the hot body there.
And that's what causes
this increase in power.
So why do we bother doing that?
We think that there are a number
of places of application--
I think, in the course, you
guys have contemplated--
or about to contemplate a number
of different sources of energy
as well as uses of energy--
so one of the application
domains is vehicles.
And we'll come back to
this slide at the end
to discuss it in a
little more detail.
There's solar energy,
portable power, industrial,
which is the first one that
we're working on right now.
The other one not shown
is building power, a cogen
for a building like this.
So the first one is waste heat.
There is lots of waste
heat in lots of places.
The focus right now
for our technology
is industrial waste
heat, the kinds of things
that you see in these pictures,
specifically a glass plant.
These are the basic modules.
These are the chips of which you
saw a schematic a moment ago.
So this is actually
a chip stack.
Each one of these is a pair
of chips-- the hot chip
and then below it, the
cold photovoltaic chip.
So we build them into arrays.
And then we take these
modules and we build those
into arrays, like this, where
we have a housing on the outside
and then the chips go on
a mounting and control
substructure, if you will,
which is mounted inside
of this hollow housing.
So the hollow housing protects
from the outside combustion
gases, et cetera, allows the
heat to go through the surface
into the chips,
makes electricity.
And that's it.
It's a very modular technology.
And that's one of
the promises of it,
that it can be deployed-- we
call it kind of noninvasive.
And you've talked about
disruptive technology
some in the class,
which has become
an important understanding
in the business of bringing
all technology-- and not
even just technology,
but products to market.
And the idea of
disruptive technology
is the new technology
comes along
and it's not very
good, technically,
compared to sort of
the incumbents that
are on the market.
But it finds a niche
where it can perform.
Often the niche is
called noncompetition.
So developing a product--
you look for a place
where there is no competition.
And this is an
example of a place
where there is no computation.
This sits outside a coal mine.
Coal mines nowadays, they go
down in the ground, and then
the coal-- and then the front,
the digging front, if you will,
the interface between
the air and the mine
and the coal that's
still on the ground,
it comes down and then
proceeds horizontally.
And one of the issues
with coal mines, as--
is there anybody who
has not heard of a--
let's see how do
we want to ask it?
Has anyone heard of a
coal mine explosion?
Raise your hand.
OK.
So most folks have heard
of coal mine explosion.
So why the coal mines explode?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: Methane.
BOB DIMATTEO: Please?
AUDIENCE: Trapped methane.
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
Trapped methane, exactly.
Whenever you're digging
up coal, you also
liberate trapped methane--
natural gas-- very explosive.
And so they go through lots of
ways of controlling the methane
content in the air so that
the coal mine doesn't blow up.
But they do blow up some time.
And so what people have
started to do is drill down
in front of the coal mine--
there's this vertical face
that's coming horizontally
under the ground--
they drill down
into it like this
and they liberate the
methane in front of that.
And then what do they
do with the methane?
Well, this is what they do with
methane, believe it or not--
oftentimes.
I mean, if it's big enough,
if it's stable enough,
then they will actually
feed it into a combined
cycle or some type of combustion
system to make electricity.
But first of all, the
coal mine front is moving
and steam turbines
don't like to be moved.
And so that's why you
see this very portable
looking infrastructure here,
that they actually move it
as the coal mine is moving.
And what they need
to do is they just
need to destroy the methane.
So here is methane being
destroyed in that inner pipe
there.
And the idea is to just
take panels like this,
and to run them down
the middle of that tube
and to turn that
into electricity.
And so no one's really
doing this right
now because of some
of the reasons cited.
You could do it with--
maybe we should
ask the question.
So are some of you are familiar
with steam turbines, or?
OK.
All right.
So you could imagine
putting condensers in here,
gathering steam, and
running steam turbines,
and making electricity.
But the idea is if
you had a module--
sort of like a photovoltaic
module, but made out
high-temperature materials that
you could put in it, easily
move, that would be preferable.
And the reason that
this is sitting here
in this picture the way it
is because the steam turbines
are not feasible now.
And so what we're going-- this
is an example of noncompetition
in the energy space--
and clean energy
space in particular,
because it would be a
way of making electricity
with zero net emissions
relative to the status quo.
I mean, this is the status quo.
So those emissions
are going out anyways.
If some of the heat
can make electricity,
that electricity's
zero net emissions.
So this is an example
of noncompetition.
We go after that, we could
not compete against GE's gas
turbines right now.
The performance of our units
are not good enough to do that.
But they are good enough to
do this in the near term.
And just as the original
integrated circuit chips,
when they first came out,
they didn't immediately
displace tubes.
But they got better
and they got better.
And I think Hiram talked
about the disruptive
example of the Sony radio.
There were still tubes in
radios for some amount of time
after those chips were in
those tiny little radios.
And so you could kind of
view our chips as an analog
to those chips and
those transistors.
And this is an application
to the transistor radio.
They had the
transistor radio had
to be able to move into
kids' bedroom, et cetera.
Here, it has to be able to move
with the front of a coal mine.
Another application similar is
combusting volatile organics
as they're loaded
on and off of ships.
So in the back
here is a harbor--
this is down in Houston.
In the very back,
you can actually
see a little tiny flare,
which basically a flame
sticking out of pipe, which
is the older way of doing
these things in which people
have tried to eliminate
because flaring of--
flaring of natural gas
reduces the greenhouse impact
by about a factor of 20.
So if you have natural
gas and you just
vent it to the atmosphere,
and you compare that
with burning the natural
gas before you vent it,
you reduce this global warming
impact by a factor of 20
by burning it.
So in a way, flares
are a big advance
on just venting natural gas.
But flares have their
own pollution issues.
And so what has
become prevalent,
particularly in the most
developed countries at least,
are enclosed flares.
So this is a stack, basically.
And it encloses a
flare like this flame.
So as the ships are loaded
here, the volatile gases
that fill the tanks before the
liquid goes in gets pushed out
and it has to go somewhere
so it doesn't explode.
And where to go?
It goes to this right here.
It gets burned, and that
heat is just liberated.
And so we are working
with a vendor that
would put our panels
right across this tube,
right in this flame to convert
that heat into electricity.
So it's another example
of nonconsumption.
I mean, these things are
running all the time.
And that heat is not being used
because there's no good way
to do it right now.
And this is just another
example of the same module
that you saw.
Bigger panels-- this
is the kind of panel
that might go into a
glass factory, which
is depicted here.
So natural gas comes in here, it
burns, it melts sand, and lime,
and things, which get
pushed into this big furnace
with bulldozers--
literally, it's quite amazing.
And they melt it and it
becomes like volcano lava,
sort of, in here--
it's actually glass.
And then out the other
end, it slows down
and becomes plate glass
like for the windows
up there, et cetera.
And so this is the exhaust duct.
The exhaust comes up here, and
right now, a type of furnace
called oxyfuel furnaces where
oxygen is taken out of the air
and put it to the furnace,
they create the heat.
The heat just goes
up the stacks.
Our panels would go in there
and convert that to electricity.
That's actually the first
application that we have--
that we are working
on developing.
So I'm thinking about
pausing at some point.
And I guess one question
is, how many of you
are not electrical engineers?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Lots of
chemicals and mechanics.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
How many of you are
not chemical engineers?
OK.
And how many of you are
not mechanical engineers?
How many of you are bio-folks?
OK.
All right.
And I know we have some DUSP,
and some poli-sci folks,
and ocean engineer folks today.
So OK.
So this right here
is an actual picture
of the same kind of furnace
that you saw-- actually,
the exhaust port of it.
And this is the same kind
of housing that you saw.
And this is some
initial testing that we
were doing moving the panels
in and out of this facility.
This is an earlier version
before we came to this--
what we call product platform,
which is the basic architecture
that we've been
talking about to date.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Do you
want to say a little bit
about the journey that got
you from an undergraduate
interested in energy to this?
BOB DIMATTEO: Sure.
Yeah.
I'd be happy to do that.
Yep.
I initially kind of got
interested in this kind
of market here.
And how many of you think you
might someday start a company
or be part of
starting a company?
Wow, that's a lot.
That's more than-- well
more than half the class.
OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] energy.
BOB DIMATTEO: So what
are some of the ideas
you're thinking
about, just to get
a few examples on the table?
Samuel?
AUDIENCE: Well, I think solar
thermal fuels could be cool.
BOB DIMATTEO: Solar
thermal fuels.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BOB DIMATTEO: So building like
liquid or gaseous fuels out
of solar thermal energy?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like
finding some molecule which
can like-- acts as
like a photoconverter
and take the sun's energy and
store it as chemical bonds.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
OK.
Sort of artificial
photosynthesis?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
All right.
Cool.
Somebody else?
A lot of hands went up
for starting companies,
including energy companies.
Oh come on.
Yes.
Back there.
AUDIENCE: Biotechnology.
BOB DIMATTEO: Biotechnologies.
OK.
Can you say, in the energy
context or different than that?
AUDIENCE: Probably
not energy context.
BOB DIMATTEO: In the energy--
AUDIENCE: No, probably not.
BOB DIMATTEO: Probably not.
OK.
What realm?
Medicine, or?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Probably something to do with
medicine and pharmaceuticals.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
OK.
Someone else-- either
energy or not energy.
Let's see, who else
had their hands up?
Engineers are so engaging.
[LAUGHTER]
I love them.
I spend my whole life with them.
AUDIENCE: A lot of folks
defeat the stereotype.
BOB DIMATTEO: So what else?
Even if you're not
interested in it
yourself, something you know
that somebody else might start?
Christopher, yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
A system for converting hydrogen
into ammonia for fertilizer.
BOB DIMATTEO: Oh interesting.
AUDIENCE: Because like
I'm originally from Iowa,
and most of the things we have
a lot of is water and wind.
And wind energy electrolysis
to produce hydrogen,
and using that to produce
ammonia because we also have
a lot of farms in the area.
BOB DIMATTEO: So
then that fertilizer
would go into the
food production then.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Because wind energy, a lot of
times where the windmills are
is far away from where the
electricity is consumed
and you lose a
lot to resistance.
And so would be
economically more
efficient to produce
ammonia out of it.
BOB DIMATTEO: That is
a really cool solution
to having to ship--
build big grids
and ship the power all around.
So there's wind in Iowa, and
there are farms in Iowa--
wow, that's neat.
Somebody else?
All right.
Let's see.
So who has not--
who is thinking--
who is not thinking
about starting a business?
All right.
So do you mind if I just
call on a couple of you
to say what you're
thinking about?
Latifa?
AUDIENCE: I have no idea.
BOB DIMATTEO: But you think
you might start a business.
AUDIENCE: I mean, maybe, if
the right idea comes along.
I mean, [INAUDIBLE].
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
OK.
Yeah, Scott?
AUDIENCE: I think
for myself, and I'm
guessing for a lot of
people in the room,
I want to start a
business at some point,
but I don't have any
good ideas yet, which is
why I haven't pursued that yet.
So I think that like
a lot of people at MIT
have the entrepreneurial
spirit, but just don't
have the good plans yet.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
That's important.
Yes.
First name?
AUDIENCE: Sean.
BOB DIMATTEO: Sean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Well, for me, I think even if
I were to have a good idea,
I don't think I
would even venture
into trying to start a company
at this point in my life.
I think that there
is valuable insights
I could gain by working
in industry for a while,
whether it's engineering or not.
And as you get more
experience, you actually
understood how things
work in reality.
Then at that point, the idea
that you thought it was good,
maybe it wasn't.
And if turns out
to be, then you'll
have more experience to
actually make it happen.
BOB DIMATTEO: Makes
a lot of sense.
AUDIENCE: It's not
about the idea.
It's about the experience.
BOB DIMATTEO: Absolutely.
Right.
It's the idea and
everything else
it takes to turn that into a
product, doing something useful
for people in the real world.
OK.
One more input, just to have
a little collection of inputs.
One more-- anyone
want to jump in.
Columbus?
You thinking about what--
what year are you in?
AUDIENCE: I'm a senior.
BOB DIMATTEO: Senior.
AUDIENCE: It's the intersection
of kind of the environment
and energy sector.
So how renewable impacts
on environment [INAUDIBLE]
energy system.
So I'm not really sure.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
OK.
Good.
So just based on the very little
you know about our technology,
make an argument for starting--
which one you would start in.
Because one of the most
difficult things in launching
a business, whether you're
doing it as a startup
or whether you're doing it
in an existing large company,
is what market to go
after first, right?
And there are advantages
and disadvantages
to different markets.
One of the advantages doing
something in a large company
is you may be able to go
after more than one market
at the same time.
But oftentimes, not.
So it's sort of like
selecting a spouse, right?
There are lots of different
interesting candidates
in the world, right?
And how do you narrow it down
to one particular person?
It can be a painful process?
And so this can be a
painful process, too.
So somebody say something
about why you would or wouldn't
choose one of these four as
an initial launch market?
Yes, Samuel?
AUDIENCE: I would say take
the one with the lowest
barrier to entry.
BOB DIMATTEO: Lowest
So what do you mean
by barrier to entry?
AUDIENCE: Like thinking about
like what sort of things
are going to stand in
the way from getting
your product into actual use.
And I mean like things where
there's a lot of infrastructure
to go through, or even like
really established industries,
they can be kind of hesitant to
take on new technologies, where
things that are kind
of less established
oftentimes will be more
open to just changes.
BOB DIMATTEO: So how
might you address that--
did you have, right here?
AUDIENCE: All right.
I did have something to say--
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah,
please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Oh, I was going to say,
if I were to choose,
I'd go in more of a
[INAUDIBLE] because it
seems like the market is there.
And it seems like it's growing,
like not only [INAUDIBLE]..
And I think that there'd
be more potentially.
Like, [INAUDIBLE].
But since solar's more,
I guess, uncertain,
it's more uncertain
than like industrial,
like it seems like there's a
lot of [INAUDIBLE] happening
in there right now.
Automotive-- I guess that
would be my second choice
if I had to choose right now.
[INAUDIBLE]
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
These are really good inputs.
Charlotte?
AUDIENCE: I think I would
go with industrial, just
because a lot of--
I mean, for solar power
in like industrial areas.
A lot of times
industrial plants are
located like outside of
cities, where there wouldn't
be as much like interference.
And I think that--
I mean, obviously, like
industrial plants produce--
like use a lot of
energy [INAUDIBLE]
generation, so that
seems like a market.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
Very interesting.
So we have low barriers
to entry, portable power,
industrial sector, right?
Interesting.
John-Mario.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So I think--
I mean, all of those
four are pretty capital
intensive as far as
starting something goes.
So I think scalability
will be a big factor.
So that's one thing also
industrial is very interesting,
because if you
look into a lot of,
I guess, clean energy
initiatives tend
to be very focused on
like the utility sector,
how you can make things more
efficient-- or industry,
in terms of manufacturing.
And I think personally,
there's too much
emphasis focused
entirely on just--
for startups, just
in technology per se.
But I don't personally
see that meaning,
for example, consulting
firms advising
how startups can secure
government grants,
or how startups can position
themselves to take advantage
of existing policies related to
energy or something like that.
I think there are a
lot of different areas
that you can use
knowledge about energy
and so on, but without
necessarily producing
anything, mostly advising
for this as well.
BOB DIMATTEO: So there's a lot
more than just the technology.
AUDIENCE: Right.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
These are all really
important points.
And as engineers, that may be
one of the hardest ones to get.
It sounds like you
guys probably already
have a very good sense
of that, the ecosystem,
that there's more than
just the technology.
But oftentimes, the
technology is hard,
so it takes lots of your focus.
But then you've got to make
all these other decisions.
So in our case, we really
struggled with portable power
because it's small.
And so compared to the
industrial, industrial,
you need like more chips, which
requires more capital, more
manufacturing capacity.
You've got to deal
with bigger vendors,
and there's more bureaucracy
and everything else.
And so the portable power
was very attractive to us.
We ended up going
with industrial, OK?
And so any guesses as to
why we might have done that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: From what I've
seen, your technology
is most aligned with them.
They have very
energy-intensive processes that
are also capital intensive.
And a 4% or 5% efficiency
gain, something
that's valuable to
them in the long term.
And they also have
a long lifecycle.
It's not like a laptop that
has a two-year lifecycle maybe,
you're not going
to get a return.
So it's not 1,000 degrees.
And you have a much more diverse
[INAUDIBLE] whereas here you
have maybe 20 major players.
They all have
enormous plants that
operate at high temperatures.
I think you make the decision
to save 5% with your capital.
BOB DIMATTEO: Yep.
So that was
definitely part of it.
Performance-- how
good a performance?
You start with the
technology is just new.
How good does the
performance of the technology
have to get before
you can do X market?
And here, we felt that it was
more stringent because here--
say, we're going to
go into a laptop.
We had to compete
with the lithium
ion batteries that
are in laptops.
And so this kind of goes to
technical details, really.
But that was a
factor, that we felt--
there's no way you guys could
know a priori sitting here.
But we felt that it
would have been harder
to get that level of
performance, as opposed
to the industrial
situation, where it just--
basically, it's economic.
It needs to be
economically feasible.
But it doesn't have to
be any better than that.
And there's really
no competition.
Another thing was-- some of you
guys mentioned related things.
And that is, how
tightly do you have
to integrate with
other companies,
with other technologies,
with other applications?
And we felt that
in the industrial--
for example, the heat source.
What kind of heat source
are we going to use?
Where are we going to
actually get the heat?
Here, the heat would have
to be produced in a very
small combustion device--
a pretty high-tech
combustion device.
And so we would need
to very tightly couple
with another company
to do that, as well
that the heat rejection, safety,
FAA regulations, et cetera.
Whereas in the industrial space,
the heat was already there.
So it was just another
piece of complexity
that we didn't
have to deal with.
OK.
So let's see.
Let me-- that's about
all I have for slides--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: How
about your life story?
BOB DIMATTEO: My life--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
How did you get
from undergraduate
kind of interested
in this stuff to
selling to glassmakers?
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
So my life story-- so you
really want everybody to be able
to take a nap right now--
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Doesn't have
to cover all aspects
of your life.
BOB DIMATTEO: No, I know.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
So I mentioned at the beginning
what kind of triggered it,
right?
And I guess there
were two things-- then
there was an energy shock
in like the '70s, when
I was a kid.
And then I was in
late '70s in college.
And it looked like energy
was really important.
So I guess you
guys are sort of--
the fact that you're
in this class--
the fact that this class
exists and the fact
that you guys are
in this class means
that energy has gotten a
lot more visibility now
than it did, say, in the '80s.
So at any rate, I started--
what got me actually started
was an article in The Boston
Globe in 1978, in the summer.
I was sitting down the
Cape, at my girlfriend,
later wife-to-be's cottage,
reading The Boston Sunday
Globe on a Sunday.
And there was an article
that said, "Kid in Texas
Gets 100 Miles per Gallon
From '68 Ford Galaxie."
'68 Ford Galaxie was a big
car that probably got like--
I don't know-- 8 miles
per gallon on a good day--
right-- 100 miles per gallon.
So could that be true?
So who thinks that
it could be true?
Who thinks that it
could not be true?
And who's not sure?
Good.
OK.
I'm not sure.
No, I mean, it
all depends on how
you define the vehicle,
et cetera, et cetera.
There are only so many
BTUs in a gallon of gas.
At any rate-- so
it led me to the--
I was thinking about
medical school.
I used to--
I studied at a school
down the street
at the other end of Mass Ave. So
I used to drive by this place.
I have three graduate
degrees from this place now.
But the way I really discovered
it was driving down Mass Ave. i
mean, obviously,
I knew about MIT.
But I really didn't--
I really didn't understand
what engineering was.
I thought if you liked math, and
science, and stuff like that,
well, you could be
a doctor, you know?
So I figured, well, maybe
that's what I'll do.
So I was a government
major because I
was interested in
the kinds of things
that you talk about
in this course.
But I really like
math and physics--
science and math.
And so I figured,
well, I'll do medicine.
And then I read this
article, you know?
And so then they kind
of came together,
just like you guys are
doing in this class.
You have technical
backgrounds of various sorts,
and you're here learning
about the whole picture
of energy, which really is--
I mean, in some ways,
unfortunately much bigger
than just the
technology because it
makes it much more complicated.
But in a way, that's what makes
it that much more important.
And so did early
experiments in this realm,
found out about solar
energy and photovoltaics.
Came over here,
and Steve Senturia
taught the class on
microfabrication,
the interest in photovoltaics
brought me there.
I ended up spending
a semester here
while I was an undergraduate
down the street, which,
if any of you are not seniors,
I highly recommend just
get yourself down Mass
Ave, take just one course
at that other institution.
It's totally free.
It's totally easy.
It's a very different world and
you'll be glad that you did it.
You can write me for
your money back if you
don't think so afterwards.
At any rate, so I
started my first company
while I was a senior
in college specifically
to develop energy technology.
And it took probably 15 years
to really do it directly,
which is this right here.
Although, along the way--
so from in the family garage,
tinkering with engines
and trying to figure
out, can somebody
really get 100 miles per
gallon, and patient family
kind of dealing with all that.
And then right then
in the beginning
of the '80s,
difficult recession,
where do you get a job?
Do you really want
to do clean energy?
There are no clean energy jobs.
And I went to work in
the aircraft industry
because I also taken Fred
McGarry's course here
in composite materials
because I was
interested in composite
materials for what?
Why might you be interested
in composite materials
if you're interested in energy?
Wait a minute.
We got to get somebody
else, John-Mario.
Thank you.
Come on.
Kristin?
AUDIENCE: Lightweight vehicles?
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
And so they wanted to build
lightweight helicopters.
And so later on, I
realized that I--
wasn't so clear at the
time that I was really
working on clean
energy-- you know,
lightweight, strong
materials which
are now going in lots of
airplanes and vehicles.
And I thought I was in
the aircraft industry,
but I was really working--
pursuing my interest
in clean energy.
And then another stint with
a company up the street,
MITRE Corporation, another
spin-out out of MIT--
well, Lincoln Lab
spun out of MIT,
and MITRE spun out
of Lincoln Lab.
And when we started to explore
some of these concepts--
but I really wanted to try
to do things more directly
and linked with sort of
energy as the food piece
that Christopher mentioned.
And sort of the notion
that if a home--
if a home-- it's part of like--
like what's an energy
system in a home?
I know this is real
easy, but what's
an energy system in a home?
That every home in
the United States has?
Yeah, Jacob?
AUDIENCE: HVAC.
BOB DIMATTEO: HVAC.
Exactly.
So make making heat, keep
people warm in the cold weather.
And what's another energy
system in the home?
AUDIENCE: An oven.
BOB DIMATTEO: Oven.
OK.
And what might the
oven run off of?
AUDIENCE: Natural
gas or electricity.
BOB DIMATTEO: Or electricity.
OK.
So then electricity is
another energy system.
So one thought is, what if there
was a food system in a home
also--
going back to
Christopher's point.
And so just the notion of
the home as being the energy
central of your
physical well-being--
whether it's in the developed
world or developing countries,
even more important perhaps,
in developing countries.
Any rate-- so it made me
want to build a house.
And I built a house while
I was working full-time
and then built another one.
And so then I did that
for about eight years.
And we were leaders in
energy efficient housing--
no surprise.
And over the course of
time, we built some miles
of roads and 150 homes.
And then I went back
to graduate school
to more specifically
concentrate directly
on energy technology
and the kinds of issues
that I talked about earlier.
And that's what led to MTPV
with the professors here.
And then there's a laboratory
across the street, Draper
Laboratory--
it used to be the MIT
Instrumentation Lab.
And they called me up and
said, we saw your resume
in the course 6 resume book.
And now this was and--
this is in 1996.
And energy-- so how
important-- how hot
a topic was energy in 1996?
Not for those of us that
were working in the field
and dedicated, but I mean,
do you guys have any sense?
How old were you guys in 1996?
Just a couple of
examples, ballpark?
AUDIENCE: Six.
AUDIENCE: Four.
AUDIENCE: Five.
BOB DIMATTEO: Six, seven, OK.
So it wasn't on the top of
you guys' agenda, right?
But do you have a sense of
like how relevant it is today?
How much in the news it
is today versus in 1996?
More now or less now?
How many think it's
more now than then?
OK.
Yeah.
So it certainly seems that way.
But at any rate, there
were folks over there
that thought energy
would be important.
And so we started developing
this MTPV technology there.
First analysis, the visit
the Professor Haus mentioned
earlier here on campus, who once
he realized that you actually
could do better
than Planck's law,
that we weren't
violating Planck's law,
that we were just operating
outside of the limits
that Planck himself put
on his law, he said, OK,
go run the numbers.
So go back and crank
through Maxwell's equations
and do all that stuff.
And come back and tell
me how much more--
how much better can you
do that Planck's law?
And so with a tremendous team at
Draper Laboratory, many of whom
we still work with
today, we did that.
And then-- so this is part of--
one of you guys here
mentioned starting
in a larger company, right?
What's it look like starting an
energy technology in a startup
versus the larger company?
In the larger company, there
is management to deal with.
Management does the
resource allocation.
And hopefully, which
was the case for us,
they ask good questions.
First they said, go
convince Professor Haus
that you have it all right.
So when the analysis was
done, then they said, OK.
Now you're ready to
design experiments, start
doing the experiments.
We built tiny
chips, 2 millimeters
by 2 millimeters-- so smaller
than half your baby fingernail.
And sure enough, the effect
was there as the theory--
as the analysis predicted.
We published that in
Applied Physics Letters.
The government got
interested-- somebody mentioned
government funding or whatnot.
That can be a very important
part of energy technology
because how is energy--
how is energy technology
different than, say, software?
Than, say, iPhone app?
Obeida?
Do you want to take a shot?
AUDIENCE: It's more
of you have to build
your products [INAUDIBLE].
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You need the materials
to build your products.
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: More capital
for startup [INAUDIBLE]
from your own company.
BOB DIMATTEO: Right.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And so there was a recent book
written called Lean Startup.
And so this-- the
following is basically
a plug for the engineering
field, a plug for what
many of you were doing.
So this book called
Lean Startup--
and the folks at HBS
and Sloan are very much
aware of it, et cetera.
But it turns out that
it's been kind of a hit
and almost sort of a craze
in the innovation world.
But he says in it
that he assumes
that what they're trying
to do can be done.
So in other words, if you're
making an app for the iPhone,
you know that you can
actually produce it.
It can actually do the thing.
Do you do it this
way for this market?
And that's where the war gets
lost or won in that world.
But here in energy,
it's really not that way
because there's no guarantee
that things can be done.
Like we've seen
billions of dollars
go into the liquid
biofuels-- which one of you
guys mentioned-- recently.
And it's turned out that
it's very hard to do--
very hard to do.
So it really it was a
technical impediment,
which is dramatically
different than, say,
if you're in the software
world, where you basically
know that you can build
what you want to build.
And so whether you're
think about starting
your own businesses
or whether you're
interacting with management
in some big business,
that understanding of
applying the right questions
know and the right rules--
so if you're in an
energy business,
you probably want
the engineers to be
more involved in
management decisions
than maybe if you were
doing software or something.
What you really need
to know is, it's
the marketing people
that need to drive--
that need to drive the process.
OK.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Questions?
Reactions?
More about his life story?
BOB DIMATTEO: So
we-- just to finish,
we developed this
for about six years--
excuse me.
We developed this for
10 years at Draper Lab,
literally across the street.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Government funded?
BOB DIMATTEO: It was about half
internal and half government.
And from starting with just
an idea, like you guys have
mentioned some ideas,
and then analysis,
and quickly moving on
to actually building
hardware-- tiny
hardware with just
scientific proof of concept
demonstration hardware.
And then scaling up to the
kinds of panels and modules
that you see us working on now.
The last five
years of that work,
I went on in the startup,
MTPV Corporation,
which got spun out of Draper.
I came back here for a
year as a Sloan Fellow--
plug for the Sloan
Fellows program.
And actually, the first couple
of million dollars, roughly,
invested in our company was
from fellow Sloan Fellows,
which was pretty remarkable.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Draper Labs also
have-- do they have that IP?
BOB DIMATTEO: Yes.
Yes.
Draper Labs involved as well.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
did they give you the IP
or do they have the IP?
BOB DIMATTEO: I actually
had the IP here.
And so it went with me
to there and then beyond.
That was kind of part
of the original--
another important person at MIT
whose name is Robert Rines--
none of you probably had the
pleasure of taking his course.
He kind of taught one of the--
the first course probably
for engineers in innovation.
Now all you guys know
about entrepreneurship
and innovation.
Some of you are smart enough to
realize that entrepreneurship
and innovation isn't right
for everybody at every moment,
and it can be very
painful along the way.
And I'm happy to talk about
some of that if you want.
And if you were smart, you
would ask me about some of that
if you want, especially
the half of you thinking
about starting businesses.
And but anyway, Robert Rines--
so he taught a course--
it was taught out
of course 6, I'm
not sure why for starting
like 50 years ago
in innovation and patents.
And I took that course.
And he became our patent
attorney for MTPV Corporation
until he passed away
a couple of years ago.
So MIT is really all
over this technology.
And I guess--
Hiram said, you know,
you should tell them
that you think that you
guys have the potential
to get to 60%
efficiency and like
a megawatt per square meter.
And I hate talking about
those things-- it really
is what keeps us going.
I mean, these initial
niche markets,
they don't keep you going.
They keep you
focused so you know
what you need to do when
you get up every day.
But they don't keep you going.
What keeps you going is a
larger vision about something
that-- it doesn't have to
be as large as producing
50% of the world's energy.
But it's a larger vision as
to how what you're working on
creates meaning.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: One of
the things I hear you saying--
I hear in your
narrative and that I
hear from a lot of
entrepreneurs-- and, in fact,
a lot of people, but a lot of
entrepreneurs in particular
is your path has not
been a straight line.
BOB DIMATTEO: Certainly.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: And
if you sort of sit there--
sit out there and think,
I'm going to do this,
then I'm going to do this,
then I'm going to do that,
then I'm going to do that--
it sort of worked
for Bill Gates,
but it doesn't work very often.
It doesn't work very often.
BOB DIMATTEO: Right.
And not in the energy
field, it seems.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
BOB DIMATTEO: Is
it possible there
are some fields where it does
sort of go more linearly?
Like I don't know, maybe
biotech and drug discovery
and something like that?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Oh, no.
BOB DIMATTEO: No?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: But I
mean for individual careers.
BOB DIMATTEO: For
individual careers, OK.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Individual careers,
if you're going to be an
entrepreneur, a lot of people--
I was with this
startup and it failed,
and I worked with this company.
And then I did this, and then
three of us had this idea.
And you don't sit here
at 20, 21 years of age
and you see that path.
BOB DIMATTEO: True.
Yeah.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: The path
opens up in front of you.
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
Oftentimes true.
And it's why there's a
lot of merit in starting
a career in existing companies.
Because as the young
man pointed out,
you do get lots of
experience and knowledge
that addresses those kinds of
dilemmas and risk, et cetera.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Questions?
You want to hear about the pain?
Ready to hear about the pain?
Give them a little pain.
BOB DIMATTEO: Well,
I'll invite my wife in
to give you the pain, right?
Yeah.
So when you're with startups
and you're getting them funded,
that can be challenging, right?
So have any of you
funded anything to date?
You know, even like lawnmower
business when you were a kid,
you bought the lawnmower?
Yes, over there.
AUDIENCE: Like raise
funding for something?
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm doing a project
this summer in Africa.
And we have to raise a little
less than a thousand dollars
to join the project.
So that's an initiative
from the companies
to sponsor us themselves.
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
So where are you
in that process?
AUDIENCE: Excuse me?
Where are we?
BOB DIMATTEO: Yeah.
In the fundraising process.
Money's in the bank?
Talking to--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
we're just-- we
recently [INAUDIBLE]..
BOB DIMATTEO: Congratulations.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Nice.
BOB DIMATTEO: That's
a real big deal.
Yeah.
And what are you
doing in your Africa?
AUDIENCE: Will you be
able to transfer it,
are you actually
going to transfer it?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm hoping
we'll see something soon.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK.
AUDIENCE: You will, I'm sure.
BOB DIMATTEO: Well, that's
an important point to be at.
The final little legal
details, and the little words
and everything else,
that can take a while.
It can take a while for the
money to actually show up
in the bank.
So you can't count on it
until it's actually there.
But sounds like you
guys are very close.
Congratulations.
What are you doing?
AUDIENCE: Well, we're
launching a robotics league.
BOB DIMATTEO: Robotics league?
In which country?
AUDIENCE: Nigeria.
BOB DIMATTEO: Nigeria.
Very cool.
Wow.
Was there another hand?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I raised funds
for a high-school business
that I started.
BOB DIMATTEO: Really
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is was basically just selling
greeting cards to corporations.
And we raised money
by allowing people
to buy shares in the
company because we
decided to liquidate it
at the end of the year,
so we raised $600.
BOB DIMATTEO: Excellent.
AUDIENCE: That
was all we needed.
BOB DIMATTEO: OK, so you get
two real entrepreneurs here.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Asking people for money
is an interesting experience.
BOB DIMATTEO: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: OK.
Any other questions?
I did promise you
sort of a half an hour
or something completely
different, so we'll do that.
Thank you.
BOB DIMATTEO: Great.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you all.
Pleasure speaking with you.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
So to compromise
between those who wanted
that talk and those
who wanted this
talk, I'll give you
a little bit of what
I would have tried
to make an hour and
a half out of if you
had voted for economic
development and green growth.
This story starts in '87
with the Brundtland Report,
a Commission chaired by
Gro Harlem Brundtland,
a woman who was a former
prime minister of Norway, that
coined the phrase
sustainable development
and gave it the definition
that you see there.
And in that first small bullet
is sort of the economist's
interpretation.
And that is the economy has
a certain set of assets,
intellectual capital,
and physical capital,
and the environment, and the
natural world, a set of stocks.
And the notion is
you should pass on
to be sustainable
a set of stocks
that are as desirable as
the set you inherited.
The first President Bush
called that stewardship.
Since he was a Republican,
nobody used that term.
But that's the concept, that you
have a certain set of assets.
So you could say, for instance,
that economic development
in 19th century Britain was
arguably sustainable, right?
They burned all the coal, the
country was dirty as anything
for decades, but
they came out of it
with tangible capital,
intellectual capital,
a whole set of other assets that
provided standard of living.
Saudi Arabia is mostly spending
the oil money on consumption.
So when the oil goes--
British coal is long
gone, but Britain used it.
And the issue is that when
the Saudi oil is gone,
that generation is not
going to have the assets.
Now it's a little vague, right?
It doesn't distinguish
between intellectual capital
and species.
And it doesn't say
anything about poverty.
And this question of the
future generations' own needs--
I mean, if the future generation
wants to only play video games,
then wiping out the
elephants won't matter.
But if future
generations actually
care a lot about
the natural world,
then having great video
games is not very important.
So if you don't know what their
needs are, it's a little tough.
And you know I was once
interviewed and asked
what I thought sustainable
development meant,
and I gave the
Brundtland definition.
And they said, is
that all, you mean?
That's kind of narrow.
And I said, what do you mean?
They said, what about
sustainable communities,
and sustainable lifestyles,
and sustainable--
it's gotten to mean sort
of everything that's good
and wholesome and green--
and a little vague.
But nonetheless, start with the
sustainable development notion.
The next big event was
the 1992 Conference
on Environment and Development.
This was the conference that
led to the Framework Convention
on Climate Change
and really started
that conversation-- the Kyoto
Protocol and all of that.
That was a big deal.
172 governments participated.
108 heads of state or
heads of government went.
That's huge.
And what came out of
it was a lot of paper.
But the Framework Convention
on Climate Change,
which really structured
all the subsequent debate.
So now we come to
20 years later.
And you've got this
whole UN machinery.
And we ought to have
a conference Rio+20.
Well, if the headline
was climate in 1992,
the question is, what's
the headline now?
And that leads to the green
growth discussion, right?
So you began to get--
beginning a few
years ago, you began
to see staff papers
emerging talking
about the green economy,
and green development,
and green growth.
Now I have to say,
I've read a lot of this
and the definition is
not entirely clear.
It is described as a subset
of sustainable development.
And it seems to be that subset
of sustainable development
strategies that doesn't
involve degradation
of the natural
environment on the way.
So the British
development wouldn't be--
might be sustainable because
at the end of all that dirt,
they had high living standards
and the prospect of higher
living standards, but not green,
because the environment was
degraded rather substantially.
It recovered, but it was
degraded substantially
in the process, and I'm sure
species were extinguished.
So maybe you could do
fossil fuels and be green.
I think so.
But if you think about
alternative ways of doing
sustainable development,
there's another--
another part of the World Bank--
the World Bank, the UN,
the OECD, and others
are talking about green economy.
If you go on the World Bank
website and you look carefully,
you see papers on
inclusive growth.
And that says, well, you
have to be sustainable,
but you should focus on poverty.
Green growth says, you
ought to be sustainable
but you should focus
on the environment.
OK.
Where do you go from there?
Well, this is what is sort
of the interesting thing.
Particularly the UN
now argues that if you
make very large
investments in going green,
growth of living
standards will increase.
The phrase that's used is,
"a new engine of growth."
Now if you're a
cynical economist,
you realize that
not only does that
mean there's a free lunch, but
one we'd all be paid to eat,
right?
Going green will
raise living standards
after a very short
period of time.
So what I want to do is talk
a little bit about that.
You can imagine how I
and others got engaged.
This was sort of very--
if you don't know this world,
the World Bank and the OECD
and the UN have a lot of--
not to insult
anybody, but they have
a lot of very smart
people without much to do.
So a lot of papers
generated, and mostly, people
pay little attention to it.
But suddenly-- and I'll get
into specifics-- suddenly,
you have these organizations
revving up for a big world
conference talking about--
talking about massive changes
in investment strategy.
And I'll give you a sense of it.
So economists have begun
to write about this.
What's on the reading list--
What's on Stellar is a
couple of the shorter
I think World Bank and--
I don't remember whether it's
UN or OECD publications--
piece of mine commenting on
this whole thing that's--
it'll be the introduction
to a special issue
of Energy Economics.
And then some other papers
that I want to talk about,
about some of the issues.
So let me talk about just
some of the issues here.
One issue that everybody
points out is absolutely right.
GDP doesn't pick this up.
GDP-- we talk about stocks and
flows, you have family silver,
you sell the family
silver, you have a party,
the party shows up in GDP.
The fact that somehow the
silver's out of your hands--
or it shows up in sort of
your consumption, certainly.
If you burn down--
and there are plenty of
African countries, plenty
of other countries, that
have basically burned down--
New Hampshire did
it, Vermont did it--
you burn down the forest to
fuel economic development.
There's a sense in which you're
changing one asset to another.
Certainly, just looking
at what gets produced
understates the cost.
So if you look at net
national product which
gets depreciation
of some assets,
it subtracts from
gross national product.
It picks up some of
this, but properly
measured, you'd want to take
into account the fact that what
happened in 19th century
Britain was they paid
for economic development in part
by trashing the environment,
in part by killing
people with the health
effects of all that
smoke, and degrading
the natural environment.
So you'd want to take that
into account when you said,
what's income, what are
living standards, really?
We don't know how to do that.
There's work at the UN,
there's work at the US.
But part of the
green growth argument
could be that what
you want to measure
isn't GDP growth, but growth
in living standards, taking
into account all
this other stuff,
taking into account
changes in health,
taking into account changes
in the natural environment,
and so forth.
So you could say, OK,
that's a relevant point.
Another relevant
point is they talk
about increasing investment,
taking 2% of world GDP
and investing it
in green things.
Well, if you make
massive investments
and they're not terrible,
they will eventually
raise growth, right?
So you're increasing-- there
are numbers in my paper.
They don't matter.
But it's basically
what the UN is
saying is the world
as a whole needs
to make a massive increase
in green investments.
If you do that, you
probably will raise growth.
That doesn't mean
it's a good idea.
If you doubled the
US capital formation,
you'd raise us growth.
A, how do you do it?
B, is it actually a good deal?
But the kicker here,
most of these models say,
here's how we raise growth.
We raise growth by reducing
environmental limits on growth.
What would
environmental limits be?
Well, in the limit,
everybody gets sick
and production and
productivity falls off.
So if you've ever
tried to breathe
in large Chinese
cities, you get a sense
that there is some theoretical--
that this may be
more than theory
in some places at some times.
But globally, probably not.
So two good points and one point
that's sort of OK in theory.
The good points are--
in terms of going
green-- that GDP growth
isn't really a good measure of
growth in standards of living.
It isn't a good measure of
sustainability, period--
sure.
Increasing the
rate of investment
in green technologies
and lots of other things
will raise growth.
Yeah.
So would investment
in railroads,
so so would investment
in highways,
so would investments
in education.
But that's certainly true.
It is possible that
one way going green
increases economic growth
is by sort of reducing
environmental limits.
The soil's exhausted, the people
are sick, et cetera, et cetera,
the aquifers are depleted,
and you're stuck.
That is certainly possible.
And if you're really
a pessimistic person,
you can look down the
road, and climate change
is another set of mechanisms
that could do this.
But is it globally
quantitatively
important in the near term?
No evidence.
OK.
More relevant points.
Certainly in rich countries,
you can make the argument
that, yes, we should be greener
than we are, particularly
in this country.
If you think carbon
dioxide does anything,
it probably makes
sense to switch--
that understates the case to
switch to less carbon-intensive
growth paths, cut
emissions, conservation,
shift to natural gas.
The interesting question,
and the politically tricky
question, is in poor countries.
Because the green
growth story is
a story not about
the rich countries,
it's a story about
mostly poor countries--
massive investments in going
green in poor countries.
Well, massive investments
in almost anything sensible
in poor countries
would be a good thing.
Where does it come from?
Probably doesn't
come internally.
This is the climate problem
revisited in a way--
probably doesn't come internally
because they don't have it
and they have other priorities.
Again, telling the Chinese
not to use the coal
while so many millions
of people live in poverty
is a tough point, tough sale.
Massive foreign aid?
Well, appropriating
massive foreign aid--
again, there's some numbers in
my paper, about $400 billion
a year from the US.
Imagine walking into Congress
and saying, yes, yes.
I know we have problems but
we need to send $400 billion
a year in foreign aid.
You would not get a
vote on the floor.
vote in a committee.
And the other problem
is the history says,
if you dump lots of
foreign aid on countries
that don't have good
governance structures,
you don't get good results.
It gets stolen.
It gets wasted.
So that's not likely.
So without the aid, how
can you possibly, say,
in Africa, in particular, where
there is hydro potential, where
there is coal, and where
there is a lot of poverty,
why not use it?
Now you can say--
you could say--
actually, that's wrong.
You can say the equity
issues are absolutely clear.
We talked about this when we
talked about climate change.
If I'm a poor country
and you say to me,
we really need you to go green.
I would say to you, you didn't.
You got rich.
You burned your coal.
You cut down your trees.
Why can't I?
If you give me
money, maybe I won't.
But maybe if you give
me money, I'll waste it.
It'll go to a bank account
in Switzerland or the Cayman
Islands.
Or I'll hire my
brother-in-law to build a dam.
So this is sort of
a terrible thing.
Now this is
something that's sort
of not on, as the English say.
There's just no way to get it
done without massive transfers
of aid, and there's no way
to get the massive transfers
of aid done--
as far as I can
tell, in any case.
One point I do want
to make, though,
and that is while you're
thinking about startups, one
of the really
interesting opportunities
globally is the large
number of people who
have no electricity, period.
Who are off-grid, who
are in rural areas.
And that's one of
those interesting
bottom-of-the-pyramid
opportunities that a lot
of people have tried to
crack because having lighting
at night makes a
huge difference.
It means kids can
stay in school.
It means the family can
work after the sun goes down
at various things.
But in particular,
kids can study.
And there are a lot of
people who have tried
to crack that economically.
Usually some version
of solar plus storage
deployed at the community
level or solar lanterns that
could be sold cheaply and
charged in the daytime
and used at night.
So there are lots of
opportunities there.
It isn't massive.
The other thing to point out is
one of the real tragedies here,
and one of the reasons why
the whole green growth notion
is compelling, but painful.
And that is, again, there's
a piece on Stellar--
if you ask who's going to
be harmed by climate change,
it's mostly the
developing world, right?
I mean, we can afford to
build a wall around Manhattan
to deal with sea level rise.
Bangladesh can't build a wall.
But of course, the
developing world
is also driving
climate change if you
look at the growth in
emissions, as we talked about
on several occasions.
There's just no obvious fix.
So the green growth is trying
to-- is an attempt by a whole
set of staff people to advocate
for massive change in the way
the world runs that's
probably not going to work--
not going to work
politically, which
is one reason why I didn't feel
like doing an hour and a half
on it, because I think
the air has gone out.
There will be a circus in Rio.
There will probably be 100 heads
of state or government in Rio
next month.
I'm told hotel rooms are going
for thousands of a night,
so it will be a big circus.
I'm told that the
official US government
position is that
Rio should produce
a clean five-page statement
of principles and policies,
and that the current working
draft is 260 pages long.
Diplomats do this.
So this is the story of
people trying to figure out
what comes after the Framework
Convention on Climate
Change, what comes after
thinking about sustainability.
And the answer is--
or was-- a major push
toward being green,
please, really a
serious, major push.
I think it lacks
intellectual foundation,
political foundation.
I think it will be
much discussed at Rio
and nothing will happen.
I do hate the last
talk to be so cynical.
Maybe we'll be hopeful next
week when we hear your papers.
Do you have questions or
comments on any of this?
That's sort of the-- this is
the current diplomatic state
of play.
This is an attempt to do
climate by the back door
and call it green.
It isn't going to
work, sadly, I think.
Yeah, Julien?
AUDIENCE: I was just curious
if you expected anything
like productive at
all to come out of it?
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE:
Well, you know, diplomacy
is a really strange process.
It's easy to mock, right?
Because particularly
in climate, there's
this group of
diplomats that like
to get together
every couple of years
and talk and make progress.
But without government
support, it's all just talk.
Given that the main problem
the world sees right now
is slow recovery from
a deep recession,
and given the current state of
politics in the US on climate,
I expect lovely prose
to come out of this.
There might be agreement
on something small.
They might get
something on forests.
I could give you my cynical
lecture about forest protection
sometime.
As long as you don't affect
the demand for wood--
protecting this forest doesn't
reduce the amount of wood cut.
But that's just the economist.
I expect there will
be some agreements.
I don't think they
will be very important.
And as I say, I expect a circus.
The folks in the
diplomatic community
would say that's too cynical.
Even just talking with
the whole world involved,
putting a spotlight
on these issues,
keeping up pressure of
some international kind
on governments that
don't want to act helps.
Sort of the water on a
stone view of the world.
That's what they do.
And every so often,
there will be a chance.
You'll get the Montreal--
you'll get the Montreal Protocol
on ozone depleting gases
because that
process had started.
Those meetings were being held.
New science came, the
structure was in place,
the support mobilized, bang.
We got a very constructive
international agreement.
It isn't going to happen here
because the preconditions
aren't there.
But the water will
drip on the stone.
The water will
Rory?
AUDIENCE: Has anyone-- well,
[INAUDIBLE] response to--
he was saying, the rich world
didn't follow a green growth
path, but they followed
the greenest growth
path available to them at
the time within economics.
And you could argue that
Britain, if they could have,
Britain wouldn't have
covered all their cities
in smog and soot.
But they couldn't.
The growth is good
for its own sake.
RICHARD SCHMALENSEE: Yeah.
That's a decent debating point.
But you also say, when
did the rich world
begin to take the
environment seriously?
And when did it begin to
have any impact on policy?
And that's sort of
'60s, '70s, right?
You don't see much--
you don't see much
conscious thinking about it.
The big US event was DDT and
Rachel Carson's Silent Spring,
which was-- do you remember?
'57?
'62?
Around there-- around there.
Birds were dying because DDT
was making their shells too thin
and they couldn't reproduce.
That was like oh my God,
our chemicals are actually
doing something out there.
But to most people, better
things through better
living through chemistry.
So to argue that we were
doing the best we could
is to argue that we were
doing it unconsciously.
And that may be
true, but it's not--
that's not that persuasive.
It's a good shot, though.
Anything else?
Anything else on your minds?
Feeling ready for the
quiz on Wednesday?
You were brilliantly
reviewed on Friday.
Ready to go?
OK.
Off we go.